thanks for checking out the y files my
name is aj this is hecklefish my
sidekick and whoa whoa whoa whoa what
sidekick i'm a co-host whoa hey i show
up every day i write my own material
without me you'd just be another idiot
on youtube saying words nobody cares
about i think that's a little bit of an
exaggeration it's co-host or i work you
can walk it's a vigorous speech okay
okay my name is aj and this is
hecklefish my co-host thank you anyway
we talk about scientific mysteries ufos
the paranormal ghost stories
conspiracies and all kinds of
unexplained phenomena but this is not a
conspiracy channel we try to back up
everything we can with facts and debunk
mysteries and myths when we can but
sometimes but sometimes there are
mysteries we just can't solve no those
are my favorite mine too so if you're
into weird and smart stuff then make
sure to click subscribe hit the bell
what are you doing hello it's a call to
action don't don't don't do that if they
like the content they'll subscribe you
really overestimate human intelligence
excuse
for your next me coming from just
because you were talking something
about your mind
[Music]
you